welcome everybody welcome to Facebook my
name's Steve Luscher and I work on the
relay team at at Facebook and the Sox
called zero to graph QL in 30 minutes
something that I hear time and time
again from conference attendees and
react developers is that they would love
to get started and try all of the stuff
that Greg just showed you they want to
get started with graph QL but they know
that in order to do so they're going to
be able to have to vend their data
through a graph QL endpoint and frankly
making the investment in a graph QL
endpoint atop their existing
infrastructure is kind of a barrier to
adoption right and I'm sure some of you
feel this here so what I'd like to do
today is I would like to do a
demonstration of just how minimal an
investment you can make to stand up a
graph QL endpoint atop your existing
infrastructure without having to rewrite
any of your data layer whatsoever and
I'm going to do so by sort of skimming
off the top of you know the web
frameworks du jour I'm going to try
Jango for Python developers I'm going to
try rails for Ruby developers and then
we're going to do a JavaScript example
in node 4 you know whatever kind of
service-oriented architecture that you
can think of so graph gel 0 to graph
kill in 30 minutes this is a time trial
so we better get started all right so
put yourself in the shoes of your
average Python developer you're
developing a large django app and maybe
your django app does something like this
it exposes a you know a person model and
you have a people endpoint and this
people endpoint then do some people I
can say people slash 1 to get the person
with with ID 1 and I have some
properties on a person first name last
name email username I also have an
association to some other people through
friendships here I have two friends now
let's say that I was charged with
building a user interface where I had to
render a list of this person's friends
with the first name and email of each
one of the friends I do not have enough
data here to be able to do that all I
have in the URL where I can fetch
more information about friends 2 & 3 so
the temptation might be to sort of
twiddle with the URL and add like an
include friend details you know email
first name kind of thing right or maybe
there's the temptation to you know break
off a new endpoint like people with
friend details you know slash one or
something like that some of you are
chuckling because you know that as time
goes on this can lead to an explosion of
custom endpoints that we'd rather stay
away from wouldn't it be awesome if
instead we could create a query for a
person with the ID one and if I could
ask for some field budget that I am
interested in like a first name and a
last name and an email address and a
user name and if I could dive into their
friends and pick only the first name and
email from the friends wouldn't it be
awesome if I could execute a query that
looked like this and get a response that
has exactly the same shape as the query
that I just made with only the fields
that I requested with no risk of over
fetching data that I'm not going to use
and no risk of under fetching for data
that I definitely need to render in my
user interface well as most of you can
probably guess what you're looking at on
screen is graph QL I'm going to show you
how to hey hey I didn't write it I'm
going to show you how to stand up a
graph QL endpoint in this Django app
right now alright so no cheating let's
go all the way back get checkout master
we're going to start from a blank slate
first thing I'm going to do is I'm going
to use the Python installer pip install
and I'm going to install the excellent
graphene library with the Django
extensions I'm also going to install
Django graphical graphical is the
graphical interface to browse the graph
QL endpoint that you just saw in the
browser alright
now with those things installed let's
write some Python code so a schema that
your job as a client dev is to export a
schema that describes your data universe
and I'm going to do it with graphene I'm
going to import graphene and I'm going
to export one of these schema things
graphene is a set of helper methods that
help me create a schema every grade
schema starts with a route field called
query that's of query type so what's in
a query type a query type is a subclass
of an object type object type has a name
an optional description and then it's
going to have some fields let's just do
the hello world for now let's say I want
a field called hello and it's going to
be of type string now I'm going to have
to write a Python method that returns me
this mythical string and I'm going to do
it like so resolve hello it's going to
take in a root some optional arguments
and some info some context about the
request this might be the logged in user
or you know context about the HTTP
request and now on this line it's my job
to do whatever I want anything that's
available in Django Python so long as I
return a string I'm going to cop out and
I'm just going to return the string
world alright let's see how we did
I'm going to jump back into the browser
I'm going to refresh her and say query
now I have this hello field that's
available and if I execute this query
the response was the return value of
that resolver world all right so here's
what I really want what I really want is
I want a person field and I want it to
be a field of type person type and I
want it to take an argument that's a
string and I want this now I'm going to
have to do some work to resolve this so
if I want to resolve a person from the
root get some args and some optional
info
now I'm going to have to do some work
that returns a person anyone who has
worked with Jango will recognize the
following API if I have a person model I
can use this API object get to get a
person by their primary ID and the ID I
can pull right out of args like so from
my people app the models import that
person model and I should be good to go
person is going to pull ID out of args
and it's going to use the Jango API to
read it out of the database alright this
is no good unless I tell it what person
type is so let's do it person type is
also a subclass of the object type has a
name and an optional description and
some fields first field I want to create
is the first name field which is a
graphene string alright what do you
think do I have enough here in terms of
my schema description let's jump into
the browser and check all right so on my
query I now have a person field at the
root which accepts an ID argument which
I can pass the string one and on that
person it looks like there's a first
name field exposed and when I hit run it
pulls that straight out of the database
through the Django model you didn't
change your data layer whatsoever and
now you stood up a gradual endpoint in a
Django app let's keep going we have
first name we have last name we have
email username and ID and then now we're
going to have to deal with this friends
Association I want to create a friend's
field which is fundamentally a list of
stuff and it's a list of person types
and in graphene I can just write self to
refer to you know the present type now
I'm going to need a little bit of help
to resolve
friends given that I start from a person
at this node with some optional args and
info that I don't need to use how am I
going to return their friends again the
Django Model API if I if I if I query
person friends that gives me an
association object that describes the
association between a person and their
friends and then if I call the all
accessor that's going to turn it into a
numerable list of friends that I can
return through through the resolver so
with any luck I now should be able to
query all of these other fields like so
and I should be able to dive into the
Friends Association get a first name and
an email execute this query and it goes
straight through the Django model
associations of friends and it grabs the
first name and email of my friends
Adrian and Simon all right so the Django
developer is happy this extends to all
other Python frameworks so let's see if
we can do the same for Ruby and
particularly rails all right here we go
so in rails I'm going to use the gem
installer and I'm going to gem install
the graph QL gem I'm also going to
install rails graphical to avail
ourselves with a graphical browser all
right with that stuff installed let's go
second verse same as the first I'm going
to need to generate a schema for graph
QL in Ruby it's going to look roughly
like this a schema I'm going to use the
graph QL gem to create a new schema like
so at the root of all good schemas is a
query type what's in a query type a
query type is a graph QL object type
defined as follows it has a name has an
optional description and it has some
fields on it for instance I might have
person filled which is of type person
type it takes an argument like ID which
is a string and in order to resolve a
person I need to write some code now
here's where I'm going to use active
record with rails to pull my people out
of the database active record exposes
this API right I can say person dot find
to find a person by their ID and in this
case I can pull it straight out of args
ID that should be enough to resolve a
person all right more work to do what's
in person type person type is also
similarly a graphic you'll object it has
a name
and an optional description and it has
some fields like a first name field
which is of type string I'm going to
have to do a little bit of extra work
graphing did some translations between
the underscored version of this field
and the camel cased version of the field
that I have to do manually here I have
to say the property you want to access
this is actually called first underscore
name whereas the field is called first
capital end name same for last name and
then for the other fields I'm not going
to have to do any of that I can just say
get email username and ID all right
let's deal with a friends field now so I
want to create a field I want it to be
called friends I want it to be of type
an array of these person type things and
in order to resolve this I'm going to
start from a person
and I'm going to use the rails accessor
person dot friends to go and grab that
out of there all right that was a lot of
typing and not a lot of running code
what do you think let's give it a shot
let's give it a shot I'm going to go to
localhost 3000 where the rails app is
running on my schema I have a person
field it accepts an ID property and on
that I can access first-name lastname I
can get email and a username and I hope
that I can reach into this friends
association and do the same and pull out
my friend's first names and email
executing this I pull out my friend maps
to the active record Association friends
all right so the ruby developer is happy
the Python developer is happy now I'm
going to move over to a language that's
near and dear to my heart we're going to
do we're going to do something or other
in JavaScript using node and Express
right okay here we go
round three for the JavaScript developer
we're going to npm install the graphical
gem and then I'm also going to install
Express graph QL which is the set of
helpers that let you stand up a graph QL
endpoint using Express really easily
alright let's do it
so the node example has pretty much
nothing I'm starting from I'm starting
from serious zero here so let's create
an index touch AF alright here's what
I'm going to do I'm going to import
Express I'm going to import as graph QL
HTTP I'm going to install import this
from Express graph QL I'm going to make
an app I'm going to make an Express app
I'm going to get that Express
to listen on port 5,000 whatever I'm
going to get that app to use this graph
you'll HTTP thing now I have to pass
this graph QL HTTP sing a schema and I'm
also going to tell it hey I'm in dev
mode here so turn on graphical so that
we can browse the schema alright what is
a schema it's nothing until I define it
in the following file which I will
create schema is alright I'm going to
have to import a couple of things from
the graph QL module graph QL schema for
instance from the graphical npm module i
want to export one of these new graph QL
schemas scheme i scheme a pretty sure
it's schemas and all great at the root
of all great schema starts a query type
what's in a query type a query type is
made up of a new graph QL object type
which I will now import before it's too
late
an object is made up of a name and an
optional description and some fields
which I'm going to define as follows I
want a person field and I want it to be
of type person type I also wanted to
take some arguments namely an ID
argument of type graph QL string which I
will import and then I need to resolve a
person so I'm going to write a resolve
method whoops now I didn't really think
this through because I started this node
example from scratch and I don't have a
data layer here
I started from literally nothing so
where am I going to get data for a
person
well I want to point out something
really remarkable about the resolve
method in your average graph QL schema
creation language resolved sure I can
return something that conforms to person
type but I can also return a promise
that resolves to something that conforms
to person type this is huge this opens
up the entire world of asynchronous
operations to this resolved method this
means that in this resolve method I
could like call the USPS API and I could
like mail a letter somewhere when I get
the response I could like open it and do
stuff or I could like call the SMS API
and send someone a text message and then
when they text me back then I could do
stuff with the text or something um but
I don't really have that those aren't
really real things ooh but what I could
do is I could make some HTTP requests to
that Jango REST API that we were looking
at before I could use something like the
fetch API and I could hit some you know
base URL because I know where that I
know where that Django applet localhost
8080 and the ID is going to be available
through this args thing so that looks
pretty legit that should craft a URL
that hits the Django API and you know
then when the response comes back I can
parse the response as JSON and I can you
know reach into that JSON and and grab
the grab the person so I don't know
could work especially if I import fetch
all right none of this is going to work
at all though without a person type so
the person type is an object type that
has a name and an optional description
and some fields on it one of the fields
is a first name and first name is of
type graph QL string and I'm going to
need to give this thing a little help to
resolve it from a person because of that
mismatch between camel casing and
underscoring so that should that should
do for first name this should do for
last name and then for the other ones
like email a username and ID that should
be enough all right what are we going to
do about this friends thing so friends
is a field of type it's a graph QL list
of this person type thing I'm going to
import graph to a list before it's too
late
now how am I going to resolve my friends
here's where things get interesting I
have a resolved method it's going to
take in a person so now what am I going
to do person has a friend's property but
that friend's property it's just a list
of URLs
well down there I have this URL fetching
thing so I wonder if I could maybe reuse
that to load the nested friends by URL
in the same way let's give it a shot let
me let me do the right thing and and
hoist this up and maybe create a helper
method called you know get person by URL
and get person by URL it's going to look
some
thing like this something like this
where I take the base URL and join it
together with a relative URL pulled out
the JSON returns a person okay looks
legit so far wherever I want to use it I
can use it like this where I say grab me
people slash args ID all right and now
back to the friend resolver so I know
that person dot friends is a list of
those URLs so I should just be able to
map over it calling the get person by
URL function each time that's going to
return an array of promises that can go
and grab that friend data supposedly all
right well I don't know let's see if it
works but you're not going to be
satisfied if it works you're gonna want
proof let's take a look at those Django
server logs what I should see here is I
should see a bunch of requests going
into the Django REST API if I hit
localhost 5,000 graphical all right
let's give it a shot
it looks like I have a person field so
far so good it accepts an ID parameter
and it looks like I have the usual
suspects available like first name last
name email username and a friend's field
and I hope that I can pull my user first
name and email from my friends so if I
run this I get three requests through
the Django REST API and I see my friends
Adrian and Simon from the first exercise
all right now you've opened up a
completely new world where you can write
a schema that hits a REST API Redis
some kind of crazy asynchronous service
any kind of service-oriented
architecture a thrift API you can back
that all with a single monolithic graph
QL schema and fetch them asynchronously
now some of you have a smirk on your
faces because you're thinking about how
you can break my example what if I
started querying for the friends of my
friends and the friends of my friends of
my friends and Turtles all the way down
valid query may be valid response but
what's going to happen whoa we just we
just slammed that REST API for a whole
bunch of duplicate requests we fetched
people three a whole bunch of times
people won a whole bunch of times that's
not good that's bad so for this in the
last five minutes that I believe that I
have in gray and zero to graph kill in
30 minutes
I'm going to show you our solution for
this that we've open sourced at
github.com slash Facebook slash data
loader it's a read through cache that
helps you with this use case and it
looks something like this jumping back
to the index J s graph QL HTTP I'm going
to say okay listen when a request comes
in I'm going to return you a
configuration object that tells you how
to kick off the query kick off the query
to into the schema but also I want you
to make available some context for me
and particularly I want you to give me a
couple of loaders that help me load data
in a cached way what does a loaded look
like loaders is going to be a bunch of
stuff for right now I just have a person
loader what's in a person loader a
person loader is going to be one of
these new data loader things
here's how you configure data loader you
give it a resolver and the resolver is
designed as follows given an array of
keys return me a promise that returns an
array of things so if I can say for
every one of those keys map over it and
call that get person by URL function I'm
going to pull that over from this file
get person by URL base URL etc I'm going
to pull that up to here so now I have
get person by URL available and I'm
going to import data loader
like so alright we're thanks awesome
alright so in recap graph kill is going
to receive a request and it's going to
pass a schema graph kill true and some
loaders through this context thing
loaders is just going to be a hash
mapping person to this person loader
thing and person loader is going to be a
data loader that knows given an array of
keys which in our case is just going to
be an array of URLs how to return a
promise that resolves all those things
into the data that we're looking for
using this get person by URL method
alright how are we going to make use of
that in the schema so wherever we were
fetching before I was using this get
person by URL method that I just evicted
from this file so I'm going to pull
these loaders through and I'm going to
use loaders person load and pass it that
URL that's the key to data loader up
here I'm saying person friends I used to
be running get person by URL for each
but I should be able to pull for with
this loaders thing from the context and
then loaders person there's another
method that data loader exposes called
load many and since person dot friends
is already an array of URLs that should
be enough I should be able to load many
URLs using a data loader all right
syntax errors willing let's see what
effect this has
so Django server logs going to clear the
screen and I'm going to try and execute
this same query and see what happens we
executed the same query we got the same
response Turtles all the way down but
this time we only made exactly the
number of requests that we needed to the
backend API so that we get the
performance characteristics that we
needed to be able to wrap an existing
rest a
by using a graph QL schema in node and
Express without ever tapping our
back-end developers on the shoulder or
asking them for favors this has been 0
de Graaff 2 l in 30 minutes
also known as zero to graph QL three
times in roughly 10 minutes I hope that
it's inspired you to try out these
principles to build your build a graph
keo schema atop your own infrastructure
atop your own data layer to expose your
universe of data through graph fuel so
that you can start playing with
technologies like like relay we're going
to have a question and answer session
after but thanks for your attention
thanks for sticking with me through that
and I hope you enjoyed the show welcome
to Facebook and have a great rest of the
day
[Applause]